we are joined now by cbs senior cbs news
senior national security analyst fran
townsend she served as
homeland security advisor to president
george w bush fran good morning
the associated press is reporting that
the fbi is
vetting national guard troops deployed
to the capitol to prevent
an inside attack and as we heard in jeff
begase's piece
david martin talking to general david
hawkinson the chief of the national
guard bureau
they are screening all the personnel
coming in how unusual
is this what do you make of it
you know anthony i think people should
understand we
always going back to my time in the
white house we've had all personnel who
are going to have
any physical proximity to that event i
mean this is a
national security special event which
comes with a whole level of state local
and federal coordination
they are running national guard members
in law enforcement through their
guardian database
just to be sure they understand in the
wake of the january 6th
insurrection on the capitol where we saw
police officers capital police officers
people participating
in that insurrection they want to be
sure that they vetted everybody and i
think it's just
a natural precaution fran
we know now that off-duty officers were
part of the riots
at the capitol uh obviously people with
military training military experience as
well
but speaking about law enforcement what
do we need to do to root out extremism
in law enforcement
anthony i think that the sad example of
the capitol police
is a warning to all law enforcement
agencies and the military that we
must police our own we must look we
can't allow people wearing in in uniform
wearing q anon patches
and just let that go as their particular
political beliefs
this is a real problem you know the
fbi's washington field office got a
failing grade
from their own inspector general on
their domestic terrorism program
and i think now look all of the law
enforcement agencies realize
they have a problem inside themselves
that they're going to have to root out
and deal with to be effective meanwhile
thousands of troops have been deployed
to state state houses across the country
as well
if there is a what do you see as the
biggest threat at this point if you
think there is one
so with 25 000 national guard troops in
the nation's capital many of them are
coming from the 50 states that we're
talking about
so they've reduced the number available
for the state capitals
um many of those governors have brought
their own national guard troops into the
state capitals to protect them
hopefully what we saw yesterday where no
one showed up is what happens on
inauguration day but i think the
governors are taking it seriously and
want to be prepared
all right fran townsend thanks so much